AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME
"FRIGHTS, CAMERA, ACTION!"
THIS TIME LAST YEAR, WE FEATURED
AN AWESOME GALLERY OF PHOTOS
TAKEN AT THE NIGHTMARES FEAR
FACTORY IN NIAGARA FALLS OF
TERRIFIED VISITORS CAPTURED
MID-PANTSLOAD, AND THIS YEAR'S
GALLERY IS EVEN BETTER.
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU A PICTURE
FROM NIGHTMARESFEARFACTORY.COM,
AND I WANT YOU TO TELL ME WHAT
YOU THINK THEY'RE SO AFRAID OF.
I'M STARTING THE CLOCK NOW.
HERE'S THE FIRST ONE.
>> THEY'VE REALIZED THEY STEPPED
OUT OF NEW JERSEY FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
>> Chris: WHAT'S HE AFRAID OF?
>> PROGRESS.
Chris: POINTS.
WHAT ABOUT THEM, MICHELLE?
>> GETTING ANOTHER SISTER WIFE.
Chris: POINTS.
YES, NEXT ONE.
THIS LITTLE RED MURDER VICTIM.
>> TALBOTS IS CLOSED.
Chris: POINTS.
NEXT UP, THESE FREAKED OUT
BROS. NIKKI.
>> DEREK JETER DYING.
Chris: POINTS.
NEXT UP, THIS LONER.
GRACE.
>> HIS WIFE FOUND HIS
MASTURBATION DIARY.
>> Chris: POINTS.
POINTS.
THESE JUMPERS IN JUMPERS.
>> THE PUMPKIN SPICE LATTE NEVER
COMING BACK.
>> Chris: LASTLY THESE TWISTED
SHOUTERS. GRACE.
>> MAROON 5 IS BREAKING UP.
>> OH, NO.